plus de deux ans se sont écoulés depuis
le dernier budget alors qu'une crise
sans précédent continue de secouer le
pays
la ministre des finances tente de
montrer la voie avec un budget chargé de
plus de 800 pages
l'objectif est de répondre aux besoins
urgents doctrine et de bâtir à l'inter
la pandémie a laissé un énorme cratère
dans les finances publiques
un déficit historique de 354 milliards
pour 2020 2021 qui réduira graduellement
pour se situer à 30 milliards en 2025
2026 malgré tout christian fruits l'inde
joue le tout pour le tout et annonce un
remède de plus de 100 milliards de
dollars sur trois ans pour la relance la
lutte à court terme des programmes d'
aide économique sont prolongés jusqu'en
septembre comme la subvention salariale
pour les entreprises et l'aide aux
loyers ou coût de 12 milliards de
dollars
mais ils seront réduits progressivement
à compter de l'été un nouveau programme
temporaire de près de 600 millions dès
juin soit aider les entreprises à
réembaucher des travailleurs on veut que
la croissance économique reprenne on
veut que les entreprises évoquées c'est
le moment de revenir à la production
qu'on avait avant la pandémie pour
améliorer les soins de longue durée au
pays et faire appliquer des normes
nationales 3 milliards sur cinq ans
versés aux provinces
la pandémie à creuset des inégalités
pour favoriser le retour au travail des
femmes
un investissement massif de 30 milliards
sur cinq ans pour créer des places en
garderie à 10 dollars par jour en
moyenne d'ici 2026 au pays le québec qui
a déjà son propre système aura droit à
une entente asymétrique
beaucoup de gens et de l'aide pour les
aînés la sécurité de la vieillesse pour
les plus de 75 ans sera bonifié de 10%
en 2022
mais dès le mois d'août ils auront droit
à un versement direct de 500 $ la
ministre se défendent offrir des bonbons
prix électoraux aux personnes âgées
il mérite l'aide que en vain leur donner
de l'aide pour les secteurs les plus
touchés pour le tourisme et la culture
1 milliards sur trois ans en
aérospatiale 250 millions sur la même
période
et pour les petites entreprises 4
milliards pour les aider à passer au
numérique
il ya aussi la relance verte avec une
enveloppe de 17 milliards de dollars
pour aider les entreprises réduire leurs
émissions et créer des incitatifs à la
rénovation verte notamment en contexte
minoritaire
comment ce train de mesures est il
accueilli aucune plainte pour les pme en
crise mais n'ont aucun plan pour les les
jeunes beaucoup de dettes sans un plan
pour notre avenir 0 rien pas de
transferts en santé alors que c'est le
secteur qui était le plus mises à mal
avec la troisième vague vague qui frappe
fort
c est responsable d'avoir de l'action
donc on va continuer de se battre les
gens si le scrutin printanier semble
écarter les libéraux savent qu'il
pourrait se présenter devant l'électorat
d'ici la fin de l'année
le budget déposé aujourd'hui est aussi
une vision politique qui jette les bases
d'un programme électoral ici louis
blouin radio canada ottawa